for the second year in a row the Academy  held a nationwide contest to discover  dynamic new voices in the next  generation of filmmakers and I was  honored to be a part of the process over  a thousand college students across the  country submitted 60-second shorts  depicting their dreams for the future of  film of these six standouts which out  six were chosen sorry the winners are  here with us tonight to participate in  the telecast please join me in saluting  their fresh creative minds here are  Zeinab Abdul Navi John Paul Isaacs Thao  Thomas Nathan Flanagan Franco McKenna  millet and Bryson Kemp ladies and  gentlemen team Oscar